here it is
last year's hsc question 16 so the last
one and it's part b so you can see the
11 marks there on the right hand side
there's four parts to this question and
we're going to kind of do it in um in
three acts as it were
so take in the question have a look
there is so much going on here um that
it's very tempting to look at this and
say don't know where to start and i
think that's what half the state did
they were like forget it um i'm just
gonna go and check some i'm gonna check
if i made silly mistakes on any other
part of the paper because it's just so
intimidating to even begin right
but i already mentioned it's clearly an
integration question and it's not just
an integration question if you have a
look even in part one the subset of
further integration within extension two
the subset of further integration that
we're looking at is a
recurrence relation can you see it there
in part one you've got the integral i n
and we want to express it as a version
of or a sort of constant multiple of i
n minus one like a smaller version a
sort of stepped down version of the
original integral okay so this is a
recurrence relation we can do these
questions we know how to handle them
even if it's been a while so here's what
i'm going to do
we're going to begin and i'd suggest you
either take your screenshot of the
question on my screen now or if you go
to the front page of our class in canvas
you can go there's a i've linked you
straight to the 2020 paper you can just
scroll all the way down to question 16b
so there are your two choices
um once you've got either one of those
visible um we're gonna dive into the
beginning of part one i'm gonna start
you off and help give you some insight
into my thinking and then 7 42 and then
i'm going to give you
three or four minutes to try and get all
the way through part one and then we'll
start we'll do the same for part two and
and so on okay
let's see how we go part one prove that
i n equals two n on two n plus one times
i n minus one so this is what we're
trying to work with and i'm just going
to jot down that integral for starters i
n
equals um we're going from naught to pi
on two
and that will obviously be pretty
important later on and it's this weird
we see daisy this weird
sign raised to this awkward looking
power to n plus one and it's not even
sign of a nice angle it's sine of a
double angle for some reason
with respect to theta and uh the
particular values of n that have been
specified you can see right there are n
is greater than or equal to one and it's
also kind of implied we're in the
integers here um not kind of implied
it's sort of mentioned up here because
you're in a recurrence relation right
you're like well i'm only dealing with
integers
okay so i'm just going to pop that
domain restriction right there
now before you panic too hard right just
have you having a look at the first part
one like what are we trying to do we're
trying to form a recurrence relation
that relates i n
to i n minus 1. now you've seen before
most recurrence relations do this but a
handful of them particularly the ones
that have trigonometric functions in
them sometimes they skip a step they go
two steps down they go to i n minus two
and that's often because of the use of
the
pythagorean identity right sine squared
plus cos squared equals one so sometimes
the use of those squares steps you down
through your algebra
to i n minus 2 rather than i n minus 1.
but because there is an i n minus 1
there right what we need to think about
is well what does i n minus 1 look like
and then how do we work toward it how do
we start to break apart the original
integral to get on the road to where we
want so that's going to be the first
part of my nudge for you okay i'm going
to say well what is i n minus 1 i don't
need to know much about how to go
through this question i can get some
runs on the board some marks that will
count for something even just by saying
what this is okay
so let's begin by thinking about just
how to substitute n minus one into here
i've still got my same old boundaries
not to pi on two they are independent of
n so they just stay put
then i say sine of and at this point
i see my first and only n so i'm going
to substitute in n minus 1 right there
plus 1. so you can see here there's the
n being substituted or the n minus one
rather being substituted there and
you've got your plus one hanging on the
end there of the power
what about the angle well it's
independent of n so it's just going to
stay as two theta and then you integrate
with respect to theta okay now hopefully
it isn't too rough to see we can just uh
tease this out a teeny bit more by
recognizing that's two and minus two you
add one so that's going to leave me with
sine
raised to two n
minus one of two theta
with respect to theta okay
so we need to get some expression for i
n that will have this in it because this
is i
n minus one so the question we need to
answer first to even really get on the
road with part one is
where could that come from where could
this thing where could this sort of
appear if we go through some kind of
integration by parts process because
that's usually how most recurrence
relations are formed now i'm just going
to pause for a minute because i want you
to i wanted to take over in your brain
before i give you those three or four
minutes that i promise to work
independently on this i wonder if you're
recognizing
how this could arrive
out of
this original integral
if you combine it with an integration by
parts
process what could you do to this that
would somehow lead you here now there
are sort of two possibilities right um
you could think back to this um
pythagorean identity that i mentioned
before sine squared plus cos squared
equals one um that's that's a candidate
right
however one of the other things that you
notice is that if you're going to use
that we sort of mentioned this before
you'd expect the difference between
these two to be two right but it's not
it's only a difference of one
so therefore i want you to think right
how are we going to use this you need to
pull out a trick that we learned right
at the beginning of integration by parts
which is the integration by parts isn't
just for um dealing with things that are
very obviously sort of expressed as a
product sometimes you've got to deal
with something that doesn't like
obviously look like a product that you
have to do the work to kind of make the
product part of it and therefore the the
selection of your you and your your dv
and that kind of thing a little more
obvious okay
so here is my final nudge before i say
over to you
if i think about this original i n let's
consider
i n
i'm going to rewrite it to make the
product a little more obvious i'm not
going to tell you which are you and dv i
think you can work that part out
yourself but here's the way that i think
is going to be most helpful for us to
try and get to the result that they're
requiring us to prove in part one okay
i'm gonna break apart the index
you can see there's the two n and the
plus one there so in fact even though
maybe it's sort of like clouded from
your view because it's so weird and
complicated this is a product in in not
two uncertain terms so i'm gonna break
out one of the sine two thetas one of
them just one so if i take one of them
out because there are two n plus one of
them inside this this long product right
that will leave two n of them
sitting to the side if i've taken out
one so there's the one hanging out there
and then i'm integrating with respect to
theta okay
i'm going to hit pause now you have uh a
product here that you can clearly break
apart using integration by parts i'm
gonna give you yeah let's call it till
752 to have a go and see how far you can
get through the integration by parts to
get to the i n equals result that they
are looking for um good luck if you've
got any questions um i'm not going to
put you into breakouts just yet because
i don't think we quite have the time but
um you're welcome to post in the chat
either if you're like yes i'm done
or two i'm completely confused or three
and you can do this privately or in the
chat to everyone saying like i could you
give me the nudge can you give me a clue
okay so i'm gonna go myself on mute good
luck and we'll come back together in a
few minutes